it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning so just how much will your
mortgage be going up the bank of England
is preparing to reveal what could well
be the largest interest rate rise in 30
years we'll be analyzing how much the
hike could be and what that will mean
for your finances on today's show I'll
be speaking to a former member of the
bank of England committee which makes
those decisions at plus a mortgage
expert will also be speaking to the
climate Minister Graham Stewart not
least about the prime minister's U-turn
to go to cop27 also ahead the labor
party chair analy Stotts it is Thursday
the 3rd of November
more mortgage Misery the bank of England
is expected to reveal its biggest
interest rate rise in three decades
situation critical Council leaders
attacked the home office over migrant
processing procedures saying Kent is at
Breaking Point
with the reports that some migrants have
been abandoned in London
foreign
[Applause]
evacuation alerts in Japan North Korea
launching a series of missile tests
let down we speak to the families who
lost loved once in the Manchester Arena
bombing with the latest in quality
findings due out today
that little girl was let down 100 by the
emergency services this should be
ashamed of themselves but they allowed
that to happen
we will not stand for the shambles
Northern Mayors call for an overhaul of
rail operators as questions Loom over
hs2 I'll be speaking to the mayor of
West Yorkshire
also ahead this morning
men's mental health unless the former
England football and rugby Stars
Jermaine genus and Hugo monya while
they're urging men to show their
vulnerable sight
no no no
and memorabilia from the Legends of Rock
and Roll goes up for auction including
Amy Winehouse's iconic beehive
[Music]
morning all could there be yet more bad
news for mortgage holders today and the
bank of England is expected to raise
interest rates again this would be the
eighth time in a row as it attempts to
get inflation under control and it could
be about to reveal its biggest rise in
three decades our business correspondent
gurpreet knowing joins us in the studio
good to see you this morning
um look there will be people who are
incredibly concerned about this because
undoubtedly it will lead to rises in
your mortgage repayments however
inflation is still a new concern yeah
we're really expecting the bank of
England today to raise interest rates by
75 basis points to 3 now these numbers
might not mean like much to you don't
really mean anything but this would be
the biggest interest rate rise that
we've seen since 1992 and it would take
rates to a level that we haven't seen
since the global financial crisis more
than a decade ago if the bank moves
today it would be following in the
footsteps of the European Central Bank
and we expect the U.S Central Bank the
U.S federal reserve to also move next
week inflation is really a global
problem and it's been rising
considerably since we emerge from those
lockdowns and the war in Ukraine has
exacerbated it in the UK prices are
rising more than five times faster than
the bank's two percent Target I think
very few people it will have escaped
very few people everything from food to
transport to fuel is rising pretty
quickly so the bank is really Keen to
get a grip of that even if it might mean
some painful times ahead well let's just
do we can tell we can actually take a
look at the look at the graph itself and
it's I mean it it is pretty concerning
but there we have back there those
historically low interest rates
basically money was free for governments
almost at that point and then one two
three four five six seven eight no Rises
much of which will lead plenty people to
say look maybe the bank of England
needed to be moved a bit more quickly on
this
yeah I mean the bank has come under
criticism that they should have got a
group of inflation earlier
um some would say that at the time you
might remember when we first emerged
from Lockdown a lot of uh policymakers
were saying inflation's transitory it
might be good three or four percent and
now we're looking at peaks of 13 but
there have been some geopolitical events
that were outside policy makers control
like the war in Ukraine but I think the
really painful thing will be for like
you said uh mortgage holders and for
ordinary people because the
counterweight of rising uh interest
rates while it dampens inflation it also
dampens growth and we could do with a
bit of economic growth in the UK the
banks today is going to unveil a fresh
set of forecasts which will show that
we're probably heading for a recession
towards the end of the year and interest
rates are only going to turn the screw
out lots more from you throughout the
morning I'm sure good people thanks very
much indeed we will of course have full
coverage of the bank of England's
announcement and that will be from 12
o'clock here on Sky News
now a new Paul foreskin uses found that
people overwhelmingly blame the
government for Rising interest rates
amidst increasing pressure on family
budgets
32 percent of people say that mortgage
or rent payments have increased over the
last three months
but those paying mortgages rather than
renting well they say that they have
felt the most pain at 36 percent say
their mortgage costs have increased
and they think they know who's to blame
for that people believe that the
conservative party's economic policies
in government and the decisions made by
the former prime minister Liz truss are
the two most important factors slightly
ahead of the state of the global economy
that means trust may be gone but people
do have doubts about her replacement
Rishi sunak and let's take a quick look
at Russia at 42 percent of people
trusting the labor leader Kirsten to
reduce the cost of living compared to 34
trusting Mr sunac to do the same
uh now our other main story this morning
local Council leaders have warned that
the situation at the manston migrant
processing center is at breaking point
and have raised fears over growing
tensions and the risk of disorder all
this as the government faces a legal
challenge over the conditions at the
center in Kent following reports of
severe overcrowding we've also had
reports of some migrants being abandoned
at stations in London uh well let's head
to manston at Skies Emma birchley is
there for us this morning and Emma just
explain exactly how much we know about
this legal Challenge and indeed what
these local Authority leaders are so
concerned about
yes so the immigration Minister Robert
generick was speaking to Sophie Ridge on
Sky News last night and revealed that
the government is facing this judicial
review which will basically look at the
lawfulness of what's been happening here
you have to remember it's a processing
center where people are meant to come
for 24 hours in some cases they've been
staying a month it's meant to be for
1600 people and we've heard reports that
it's been closer to 4 000 people being
dealt with here now Mr Jim Rick said
he's been working night and day to deal
with this and that people have been
moved out to longer term uh
accommodation and he says that hopefully
within a few days the site should be
legally compliant which does make you
wonder whether what's happening here at
the moment is lawful and at the same
time we've heard about this letter
that's been sent by the council leaders
across Kent and Medway 14 of them all in
all which really doesn't hold back full
of frustration at what they called a
disproportionate pressure that's being
put on the county I'll give you an idea
of this letter so they say Kent is at
Breaking Point our public services
including Health social care and schools
already under extreme pressure from
surging local demand and the cost of
living crisis the situation at Marston
manston is critical we now have
approaching 4 000 service users
contained within segregated Marquees as
we approach the coldest months of the
year some have been on romance mats for
over a month and the letter goes on we
have hundreds of mostly Albanian service
users not claiming assignment Asylum and
being bailed and dropped at mid-kent
train stations with no follow-up where
they go or if they leave Kent and at the
same time we've also heard about a girl
in this Center breaking through the
security guards running to the perimeter
threat events throwing a mess in a
bottle over to a press photographer and
in that letter she says about how people
are getting sick she talks about
pregnant women not being looked after
properly and that 50 families have been
there over a month so clearly this very
much towards the top of the agenda at
the moment and there is a lot still to
be sorted out
thanks very much indeed
plenty coming up on the show this
morning shortly I'll be speaking to the
climate Minister Graham Stewart he's
representing the government this morning
certainly plenty to discuss with him
at just after eight the chair of the
labor party Anna Lee studs will be
joining us
and of its questions over the future of
the hs2 Rail Project I'll be speaking to
the mayor of West Yorkshire Tracy Broome
South Korea and Japan say North Korea
has staged yet another significant
weapons test including possibly firing
an intercontinental ballistic missile
[Music]
[Applause]
Japan's government initially cited these
Sirens as a warning that a missile had
overflown its territory but later said
that was incorrect they did however
confirmed that emissile had been fired
Skye's Asia correspondent Helen Ann
Smith has the latest from Beijing
the South Koreans and the Japanese
said that they believed an
InterContinental intercontinental
ballistic missile was fired that's
essentially a missile that has the
capacity to hit Targets on the other
side of the world it's believed that it
failed part way through its flight and
fell into the sea but as you saw there
the concern was high enough that sirens
were sounded in Japan a number of
Northern districts people told to take
shelter and stay inside and as you said
it comes a day after a huge swathe of
missiles were fired by the North Koreans
believed to be the most fired in any one
day yesterday and one of them actually
landed closer to the South Korean Coast
than any have previously so we're real
stepping up it actually prompted the
South Koreans to fire some missiles in
retaliation and it comes in the context
of a number of months of this sort of
escalating incremental buildup of
tension the North Koreans have fired
more missiles this year than they have
in any year since the leader Kim Jong-un
came to power and there's a real real
sense of nervousness in the region agent
were saying the North Koreans for their
part they are saying they're responding
to current military drills that are
underway between Italy in combination
with the South Koreans and the Americans
the North Koreans see that is incredibly
provocative they see that as a threat to
them despite the Americans claiming that
the drills are defensive in nature but
the real fear is what all these
escalating actions lead to the
nervousness is that the North Koreans
are preparing to undertake another uh
full nuclear test the last one
undertaken wasn't since 2017 and that
would be a huge ramping up because it's
difficult to see how the South Koreans
and the Americans wouldn't have to
respond in some form to that type of
provocation so at nervous times on the
Korean Peninsula official
Helen and Smith there now findings from
the latest stage of the Manchester Arena
bombing inquiry will be released later
today but what is already clear is that
some lives may not have been lost had
Emergency Services been at the scene
more quickly one man who cared for the
youngest victim told us that it felt
like an eternity before help arrived
this guy's enzaman Rasheed reports
[Music]
this girl's life was cut brutally short
on a day which was also undoubtedly her
happiness
sappy russos just eight years old in May
2017 was murdered as she was leaving the
Ariana Grande concert in Manchester the
attack's youngest victim she just had
this order about herself where she could
get anything she wanted just by smiling
she's just a she was just a magnet to
people they are happy memories that will
remain untouched but so will the thought
of knowing his daughter suffered
unimaginable pain
that little girl was let down 100 by the
Emergency Services they should be
ashamed of themselves but they allowed
that to happen
they should not allow a child to be
taken out on a cardboard
poster
that's full of blood from somebody else
and it's that what the second reports
from a public inquiry will address
focusing on the response of the
emergency services on the night of the
Manchester Arena attack
over months of evidence the inquiry
heard there were failings across the
board police Chiefs forced to apologize
the fire service embarrassed by their
response and paramedics criticized for
the delay in treating victims experts
revealed there were missed opportunities
to save lives including safies
it was at 10 31 PM Salman abadi
detonated his bomb in the foyer of the
Manchester Arena at 10 57 a piece of
advertising board was used as a
makeshift stretcher to carry Safi out of
the Arena by two police officers and a
member of the public she was carried 102
meters to an exit on Trinity way but
there were no ambulances in sight she
waited 17 minutes before an ambulance
was flagged down by a police officer to
take her to hospital at 11 40 Safi was
pronounced dead after losing too much
blood from her legs in her final moments
it was Paul Reed a poster seller who
stayed by Safi doing all he possibly
could to comfort her as they waited for
professional help
but like yes I was thinking in a minute
now everybody's gonna come in and
they're going to get me out and kick me
out of there but it just didn't didn't
work like that I do blame the top brass
for you know
um you know I'm not
dealing with situation probably
the Emergency Services say it is
inappropriate to comment before the
report is published when Five Years on
families are victims like Safi may feel
they're closer to the truth but they
will want nothing less than real changes
into man Rashid Sky News Manchester
and we'll be bringing more on this story
at around about 9 20. I'll be speaking
uh to Neil hodgel a lawyer representing
some of the families of the victims of
the attack
some other headlines now and Ethiopia's
warring sides have signed a deal to end
a conflict that's raged for more than
two years representatives of the
government and Tigre Rebels signed a
disarmament agreement which also
restores services and Aid deliveries
thousands of people have been killed in
the fighting which means Northern
Ethiopia to the brink of famine
new Research into the Psychedelic
chemical and so-called magic mushrooms
suggests it may ease depression and some
hard to treat patients
233 adults in the U.S Canada and Europe
were giving varying doses of
cellulocybin and depression symptoms
declined amongst all for up to three
weeks
scientists have discovered that monkey
pox transmission can happen up to four
days before any symptoms appear
researchers at the UK Health Security
Agency found more than half of
transmission occurs in the
pre-symptomatic phase meaning that many
infections cannot be prevented by asking
people to isolate if they detect
symptoms
The National Trust is creating the UK's
largest Wildflower grassland the project
will see pockets of a rich Savannah sawn
across 70 miles of the north Devon
landscape by 2030. to replace natural
habitats lost over the past hundred
years
the Liverpool manager Jurgen klopp has
said he doesn't feel players should be
criticized if they don't speak out
against the World Cup hosts Qatar it
follows calls from human rights groups
and footballers to use their status to
highlight issues in Qatar this winter
the decision was made by other people
and if you want to criticize anybody
then criticize the people who made the
decision not the sport not the
competition and not for sure not the
players so
um and now it's not fair as well that we
expect prominent that they go there and
make big political
um statements or whatever it's just not
fair
Joe Biden is one that U.S democracy is
under threat from the election result
denials of Donald Trump supporters and
the violence that he says they've
inspired the president who's speaking
just days before the midterm elections
were seats in the House of
Representatives and the Senate are being
contested from Washington our U.S
correspondent Mark Stone reports
this was no normal pre-election speech
scheduled Leighton with a sense of
urgency it wasn't about policy good
evening everyone it was about the
stability of the nation my fellow
Americans
were facing a defining moment
an inflection point
make no mistake
democracy is in the ballot for all of us
his party May well be trailing in the
polls her drubbing next week is possible
and so of course he's looking for votes
but the president sought to get beyond
that this is not about me
it's about all of us it was a warning
about what he sees is the fraying fabric
of American society
a struggle for decency and dignity a
struggle for prosperity and progress
a struggle for the very soul of America
itself
every day since he lost the 2020
election Donald Trump has cried foul
claiming continually without any
evidence that he won
you know American democracy under attack
because
the defeated former president of the
United States refused to accept the
results of the 2020 election
every recount confirmed the results
yet polls suggest that up to 70 percent
of Republican voters believe President
Trump
Mr Biden drew a line between what he
called the big lie and the hammer attack
last week on the house speaker's husband
the assailant ended up using a hammer to
smash Paul's skull
we don't settle our differences in
America with a right a mob
or a bullet or a hammer there are up to
300 Republican election deniers on the
ballot next week Trump allies like
Arizona's Cary Lake if they win they
will judge the validity of the next
presidential election an intervention
like this is extremely controversial
saying in such Stark terms that only his
party stands for democracy is he
essentially telling voters that the
nation's democracy has already been lost
and just days away from the elections
into such a tense environment it's high
risk indeed Mark Stone Sky News in
Washington
[Applause]
the Royal Mail has released its
Christmas stamp collection featuring the
Queen's silhouette for the final time
the six Art Deco style stamps feature
nativity scenes very stylish as well
with an outline of the late Monarch's
image in the top right the distinctive
profile facing left and wearing the
diamond diadem has appeared on festive
stamps since 1967.
very lovely they do too
but let's return our focused interest
rates and the rise we're expecting from
the bank of England at midday very
pleased to say everyone speak now to
Charles goodart former member of the
bank's monetary policy committee Charles
great to have you on the program this
morning and so early as well um I just
wonder what you were expecting to hear
from the MPC today there appears to be a
bit of a consensus for being around a
rise of 75 basis points
yes but I think there's an alternative
they could go for lower the 50 basis
points I hope they will be over 75
business boards because they're still a
long way behind the curve
just in terms of of what the bank of
England have been doing recently this is
what the the eighth successive time that
we are certainly expecting a reason
where it will fall we will find out at
midday what do you make of the argument
that some have uh some have been
Prosecuting that perhaps the bank of
England has been somewhat slow in terms
of reacting to where inflation is and
responding accordingly regarding
interest rates
I don't think they've been so in timing
in fact they were the First Central Bank
to start raising interest rates but
unlike the FED which has now been
raising interest rates by 75 basis
points of time but the last four goes uh
the bank has tended to raise interest
rates really rather slowly 25 basis
points and then 50 basis points and
they're actually now rather far behind
in terms of the level that they've got
to and it's clear that they've got to go
quite a long way further uh if they're
going to bring in patient back to Target
well just on on that point I mean how
successful has the bank of England been
in that endeavor so far I mean where are
we expecting inflation to to finally
plateau and and fall
well the target of course is to get
inflation back to two percent but the
question is whether the head wins from a
a worldwide declining labor force is
going to allow them to do that uh one of
the things that has surprised most of
the central banks is how tight labor
markets have been since covid began and
are likely to remain very tight and
unfortunately it's not into the labor
market as more slack more level higher
level of unemployment we're going to see
the level of inflation go down the kind
of uh levels of about two percent that
the central bank is mandated to achieve
are there are there any other options on
the table to to deal with this rampant
inflation other than simply continually
adding to to the interest rate
um not really there are always
suggestions about trying to uh fix
prices by law
but we've tried that in the 1970s 1980s
and trying to to actually legislate to
fix uh wages and prices
um really doesn't work at all well and
I'm really quite worried about the
suggestion that the government is going
to try and deal with inflation in future
by holding particularly public sector
wages uh down to shall we say two or
three percent next when inflation is
still going to be a great deal higher
that's a recipe for me having good
public sector services and for strikes
and for kinds of difficulties it indeed
certainly makes it certainly makes life
a lot more difficult if you are one of
those public sector uh servants I I I
hope this isn't a kind of a how long is
a piece of uh how long's a piece of
string question but I wonder where you
expect and where you anticipate interest
rates peaking
this is the honest answer to that is
that nobody knows because we've never
been in quite this situation before
um my guess and it's a guess and it's no
better than anybody else's maybe worse
is it will be somewhere perhaps just a
little bit north of five percent
wow but of course we have seen something
of a transition of power not the only
transition of power we've seen over the
past a couple of years but we have seen
a recent transition of power in Downing
Street Rishi sunach into number 10.
Jeremy Huntington to number 11. it does
feel that that alone and of course the
rhetoric that both have been deployed
have served to stabilize the markets
just a bit
oh absolutely and I think interest rates
will now Peak at a considerably lower
level than they would have had to uh if
we still had the unfunded massive
expansion giveaway of cartan's mini
budget
well and again just just on that point a
lot there is an awful lot of pushback
from anyone that you speak to in
government these days when you suggest
that for example you know the the rate
at which governments can borrow you know
the amount of money we're all paying on
our mortgages did any of this had
anything to do with quasi quaten's mini
budget with anything to do with the
policies of the government I mean it's
it is demonstrably true isn't it that
whilst there are certainly Global
factors uh that are affecting pretty
much every Western industrialized
economy at the moment there were factors
that were exacerbated by political
decisions taken by Liz truss and her
Chancellor
yes absolutely and you can see by
looking at the timing of the changes in
interest rates the movements in the
market that there was a clear strong and
very adverse reaction to the mini budget
yes there are many Global factors uh
pushing interest rates up around the
world as you pointed out but that makes
it all the more important that we don't
have local factors making that even
considerably worse
um Charles with me bearing in mind at
your earlier comment that as regards
interest rates you know no one really
knows your view that we could get as
high as as high as five percent how long
would you anticipate it taking to get to
that kind of point
it depends how quickly the the bank of
England which is up uh interest rates my
concern I is that if they don't start
pushing interest rates up faster than
they have been in the past we will start
getting unemployment rising and the
political pushback from that will
actually prevent from Raising interest
rates to a level which actually will
have an effect in bringing inflation
back down to targeted I think you're
quite likely that every future years
we'll see a combination of somewhat
slower growth over the next few years
and inflation
um and interest rates considerably
higher than they have been in the past
and remaining above Target
Charles it's been great to talk to you
this morning really appreciate your time
thank you
no Europe's temperatures have risen by
more than twice twice the global average
over the past 30 years the World
Meteorological organization says they've
gone out up about 0.5 degrees Celsius
per decade since 1991. after
record-breaking drought and wildfires
this year the UN describes Europe as a
live picture of a warming planet
and with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's just
take a quick look at the impact of
climate change on the planet the right
half of the screen they're showing how
our energy is being created in real time
still a significant Reliance of course
uh on natural gas they're 40.5 percent
of our energy coming uh via that at the
moment on the top left you can see just
how much warmer the Earth is since 1880
that's when modern record keeping began
and then finally that total that
alarming number down at the bottom left
there that's the total carbon dioxide
emissions in millions of tons
no have you ever encountered uh one of
these whilst swimming in the sea
jellyfish yeah not my favorite you could
well be finding lots more of them very
very soon indeed at the marine
conservation society says that more
jellyfish have been spotted along UK
coastlines over the past year scientists
are pointing to warmer sea temperatures
now the problem is that they include
these small but menacing creatures the
Portuguese Manowar now they're long blue
tentacles can cause painful welts on the
skin and a rash that for some people can
last for weeks
now if you scan the QR code on the
screen right now you can listen to
today's edition of The Sky News Daily
podcast on this episode Sally Lockwood
is exploring just how much of a threat
bird flu is to Consumers business and
Wildlife but the turkey farmer bird
expert and our Science and Technology
editor Tom Clark
time for us to see how the weather's
looking
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
it's going to be unsettled again today
and a bit cooler but Friday looking
mostly fine there'll be a fine start for
many although still very windy in the
far north and west but there will be
showers near Northern and eastern coast
sorry northern and western coast I
should say and more General rain across
the southeast East Anglia Southeast
England where they'll remain largely
overcast with further rain through the
morning elsewhere most places can expect
some good Sunny spells but showers will
develop widely in the West
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
welcome back joining me now in the
studio very pleased to see Graham
Stewart uh course climate minister at Mr
great to have you in the program
um as I mentioned to you whilst we're in
the break though there's an awful lot we
can talk about certainly on your brief
but but I do still want to to return to
where we've started every interview this
week and that's the situation at manston
can we just confirm what Robert genre
seemed to imply last night that right
now manston is is operating illegally
people are being detained there for
longer than the 24 hours that you're
entitled to do under the law uh we've
seen I think it's a 77 77 increase in
the number of um people uh in the uh
Crossings and Asylum Seekers
um we've seen this unacceptable surge in
small boats which would which is why the
Prime Minister was talking to the French
President last week why we've um uh
working with the Albanian authorities
the system is is struggling to cope and
that's exactly why we brought in the
nationality and borders build in order
to have a One-Stop processing that's why
we've got the Rwanda policy um that's
why we're but it is not where we want it
to be right right now and we're we're we
are simply looking to bounce that up uh
thousands more hotel rooms have been
um sorted out but it's uh it's it's
unacceptable to the British people and
we need to do more to tackle the the
traffickers in what is a unprecedented
surge in illegal no one is dating no one
is doubting that this government is it
is ramping up its response and is no
trying to deal with the situation at
manston but this is what Robert generic
told my colleague Sophie Ridge last
night I expect manston will be returned
returned to a well-functioning and
legally compliant site very rapidly are
you personally happy that the government
in which you serve is currently
detaining Asylum Seekers for that is
what they are at manston that he is
detaining them illegally are you are you
personally comfortable with that well
obviously not none of us are comfortable
with it we want it uh we want it tackled
we want to get a grip that's exactly
what the the home secretary's focused on
I think she's got her priorities right
and that's making sure that we we do
continue to treat people in a
compassionate way but fundamentally
behind this of course there are all
these illegal gangs and um British
people look on it with disbelief
including including the council leaders
down in Kent they've written this letter
to the home office last night just there
are a couple of bits in it that are that
that the leap out put simply there says
Kent is at Breaking Point secondary
schools in Canterbury and Ashford
currently have no year seven and year
nine places for local children due to
the unexpected and therefore unplanned
for arrivals of refugee children they
also mentioned that there are around
about 20 000 on waiting lists for
Council housing there
we're now talking about local children
not being able to get access to their
school on a human level why has the
government let this situation develop I
understand that there has been a ramping
up of numbers but it has been a pretty
consistent ramping up of numbers it's
not been some overnight exponential rise
well there has been an incredible surge
but one of the reasons for bringing in
dispersal which is one of the policies
to make sure that every local Authority
right around this country shares in
taking on this burden it is immense and
we recognize that the people of Kent and
public services in Kent should not be
carrying that burden alone and that's
why we're looking to bring in all these
measures
um and uh you know that is that is our
Focus that's the home secretary's Focus
we're not claiming it's acceptable right
now and that's why we're taking steps to
put it right just one just one other
thing to people pop in the screen then
and of course we've mentioned albanians
and there is certainly a feeling that a
significant number of those who have
been coming here have been coming here
for for criminal reasons well you know
Albania's prime minister ready Ram is
not desperately happy about this he
tweeted this last night Albania is not a
rich country and was for a very long
time a victim of Empires we never had
our own we have a duty to fight crime at
home and are doing so resolutely as
cooperating closely with others too
ready to work closer with the UK but but
facts are crucial
um so is mutual regret I think we may
have the wrong one there but in essence
what what the Albanian prime minister is
suggesting is that perhaps some of the
rhetoric that is being directed at his
fellow countrymen and women might just
be slightly over the top well I'm
grateful for the um uh the work we're
doing with the albanians and they have
been sending senior police
officers over so as to speed up
processing
um we've got a expedited system to
return albanians if it turns out that
they are not legitimate Asylum Seekers
um so we are trying to work in
cooperation but clearly there's pressure
you can see it from the councils you can
see it from uh members of parliament you
can hear it from people people and
journalists around the country it can
lead to language which is sometimes
unfortunate and it is worth putting on
record our gratitude to the Albanian
government for their cooperation
um in working to sort this out let's let
as as promised move on to your brief How
concerned were you uh by the UN
emissions Gap report that emerged
yesterday
um well we're absolutely focused on
making sure that the Glasgow climate
pact is converted into action
um and as you say the world is not on
track for 1.5 degrees
um
2.8 degrees report after report after
report
um and that is why I mean why have we
taken the actions we've taken we've cut
our emissions in this country
domestically we're only a small part of
the globe but setting an example by more
than any other major economy on Earth
but also we're also learning we're also
you know opening opening up the bidding
process for for 100 new kind of gas and
oil extraction licenses in the North Sea
that doesn't sit very comfortably with a
commitment to Net Zero it doesn't look
like it does it absolutely does we're
committed to a uh a 50 reduction in
emissions around production in the North
Sea we're managing the decline of the
Basin it is expected with new licenses
that it'll still be reducing at about
seven percent a year faster than the
globe needs to cut its oil and gas and
producing our own energy energy here to
ever hire environmental standards
stopping us spending billions on
bringing in oil and gas from other
countries it's a weird argument when you
you're going to have to burn oil and gas
up to 2050 and through 2050 even on Net
Zero to think that buying it from abroad
is somehow Superior from doing it at
home well it's going to be sold in the
same Market we're not going to get it
cheaper just because it's produced it's
not about being it's not big about being
cheaper but you're buying it from the
international market and what you're
you're buying it if you have domestic
production I mean our the tax on that at
the moment 65 percent I mean it is 7
billion from the from the windfall Levy
that was brought in
um a 10 billion next year
um it really is worth nailing Neil the
idea that us as part of a declining
Basin producing our own oil and gas when
we have Net Zero in our law when it
doesn't affect our consumption and when
we are net importers that that is
somehow bad it isn't and I really would
like to nail it I hope your viewers at
home which see that us producing our own
oil and gas to ever higher standards
leading to technology which is then
exported around the rest of the world is
a good thing I know it sounds ironic I
get in the newspaper no no climate
Minister says more oil and gas is good
for the environment in that context it
is and it's a it's an argument worth
making and I'll tell you what people in
Northeast Scotland want they understand
that argument and to see the Scottish
government wanting to abandon them and
having this argument made out as if they
are part of the problem they are part of
the transistors who live in Aberdeen who
point to the fact that Rishi sunak has
said that he doesn't want solar Farms on
Farmland that doesn't strike me as
particularly as particularly pushing
towards net zero he's also said that he
is going to scrap the pan the plans to
relax the ban on onshore wind which is
by my Reckoning indeed by by other
people's Reckoning the cheapest form of
renewable energy now those are two ways
in which we could dramatically increase
renewable clean energy production in
this country and he said no to it five
minutes after entering Downing Street
well we are committed to Growing our
Renewables which we've done more than
anyone else well we are doing it on land
and we're seeing solar I mean make
getting the balance right between uh
farmland and solar is something that
we're working on and when we have
further details to share we'll do so but
uh actually the cheapest current form of
renewable is uh you know uh on on ground
solar with onshore wind being just
behind an onshore wind is our largest
single renewable
um sector of 14 gigawatts coming from it
can you confront that which we've been
hearing in the papers this morning that
actually the Prime Minister the chances
I have been listening to kyostarma and
that they are going to expand the school
of the windfall tax on the energy Giants
Well I could be absolutely clear that I
don't think we'd go listening to Kia St
Arma but we do always keep these things
under review but on fiscal matters I
leave that to my treasury colleagues and
we will doubt we will hear more on the
17th of November just just one final
word and from you on Matt Hancock who
are no hearing is getting 400 000 pounds
for appealing on Amazon so yeah I'm a
celebrity that's nearly five times his
MP salary look is there perhaps a degree
of hypocrisy from the conservative whips
office they've removed the whip from
Matt Hancock for going to Australia they
didn't remove it from Boris Johnson for
going to the Caribbean on a holiday he
wasn't doing anything about dyslexia or
indeed from Liz truss who I'm reliably
informed is also abroad on her Halls
well we think that MPS should be
attending to their duties
and of course with so many people
working from home these days it is
possible uh to work from wherever you
are in the world it's not really
possible to do that when you're in the
jungle he wouldn't have had the whip
removed if you've been able to take a
laptop in so you can answer these
constituents emails uh I think while
you're eating various worms and sticking
your head in unpleasant places it's
quite hard Neil to concentrate on what's
going on in your Suffolk constituency I
I will tell you it will be a a nation
unifying event of that I am sure
Minister it's been I've been the program
thanks for being with us thank you
but before we move on let's take a quick
run through the papers and we start with
the Metro it reports on a man trying to
rescue his nephew from the manston
Migrant Center after spotting him in
press coverage
the eye says that people who'd been held
in the center were dumped by mistake
outside London's Victoria Station by the
home office
funnily enough that is also the lead in
The Guardian it says that Asylum Seekers
were abandoned
the express says the Home Secretary
swella Braverman is lining up three more
countries after Rwanda to send migrants
to for processing I don't think we've
actually sent into Rwanda yet have we
a political correspondent tomorrow Cohen
is here when she gets off her phone will
be able to tell me whether I was right
there we haven't sent anyone to Rwanda
yet it seems a bit a little bit
premature um should we talk about that
which we were just healing from the
minister and and on manston again
actually I think we heard it there as
clearly as we've heard it from anyone uh
within this government that the
situation there is bad and they are
trying but it is absolutely by the road
admission not what it should be not what
it should be and not going to be sorted
out immediately we heard from the
immigration Minister Robert generic last
night that the numbers there are now
down to three and a half thousand which
is well over the ordinary capacity of
1600 and that is only with these
Marquees outside and as the Kent County
Council leaders have pointed out in
their really stinging letter to the
government saying how do you expect us
to find accommodation for all the people
there they say as their residents are
also concerned as we head into the
winter months that people might have to
stay in those kind of conditions so
they've got this double whammy of not
want not having enough accommodation and
the feeling if they give it up to the
people at that site then local people
will lose out there will be crisis with
school places but also local residents
are concerned that vulnerable people are
being kept in very difficult conditions
and I think one of the questions the
government are going to have to answer
is not just how they disperse people
from the manston site right now with
accusations that some of them were
dropped at Victoria Station last night
without anywhere to go but also how they
prevent this overcrowding in future if
these boat Crossing numbers continue as
they have been they have been at record
levels this year forty thousand yeah but
the idea that that's come out of Norway
and I'm sorry is the minister appeared
to suggest I mean that's just wrong we
have seen a steady ride steady rise and
some of it was predicted but it's been a
lot higher than in previous years and if
that continues what is the answer in the
home Affairs select committee has
already asked the Home Secretary for
answers in the next two weeks about how
they prevent this sort of overcrowding
in the future Richie sunac said
yesterday the labor can't attack his
plan because they haven't got a plan for
that think labor are going to continue
attacking his plan in the near future
because they see this in as an issue in
which the government is weak and isn't
able to account for how it's going to
sort out the situation I think you might
have a point tomorrow thanks very much
indeed
welcome back Brazil's former president
Jared bolsonaro has urged his supporters
to lift blockades being staged in more
than 70 cities in the country the
protests have brought traffic to a
standstill and are hitting the economy
they began on Sunday after bolsonaro's
narrow loss to leftist Lewis inacio Lula
de Silva in the presidential election
our chief correspondent Stuart Ramsey
has the latest from the streets of Sao
Paulo
[Applause]
the president's office may have conceded
defeat but many of Jay bolsonaro's
millions of supporters have not
they took to the streets of Sao Paulo in
their thousands
[Applause]
the national flag waved above the crowds
as they gathered outside the
headquarters of the military's
Southeastern command
they're calling for an intervention but
simply they want a military coup
[Applause]
[Music]
they despise the leftist policies of
Lula de Silva and they want him out by
any means
[Applause]
the military take over and do not no
election you know we are defended our
how can I say Juliet
Liberty Liberty property family and our
people our family
foreign
[Music]
we must to fight until we
give our Liberty
[Music]
haulage lorries began the anti-lular
protest by blocking roads across the
country
they've become a symbol of this protest
movement against the election result
the president bolsonaro has asked them
to stop
I know the economy has its importance
maybe you were giving more importance to
other things now and it is legitimate
that I want to make an appeal to you to
clear the highways this is not part in
my view of legitimate protest
[Music]
many here thought the fervor of
bolzanaro supporters would have been
dampened it hasn't been they've taken to
the streets in 70 cities across the
country
you can keep up these sort of rallies if
they can close roads and perhaps affect
the economy then the military will
intervene but so far they've said very
very little in fact it appears that they
want to maintain a completely neutral
stance
keeping the momentum going when even
bolsonaro's strongest political allies
have publicly said the game is over will
be hard for these people to achieve
it was a close election but they did
lose
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Sao Paulo
no some of you will be overjoyed by this
uh fun-sized piece of news others will
be devastated Bounty chocolates no
longer meet the bar and will thus be
scrapped from celebrations boxes
um I can't believe I'm about to read
this out don't worry the Mutiny on a
bounty may be only temporary as it is
part of a trial ahead of Christmas at
the chocolate manufacturer Mars Wrigley
says that it found 39 of customers want
the coconut flavored sweet permanently
banished I have to say I'm going to pop
myself into that category it certainly
isn't my favorite at the limited edition
bountyless tubs will includes extra Mars
Milky Way and Galaxy Chocolates as
substitutes do get in touch with your
thoughts on that at Sky News Neil are
you Mutiny on the Bounty today or do you
like me think that you shouldn't have
coconut anywhere near chocolate uh now
we've been taking a look through some of
the photos that have caught our eye
today the holy fashion statement or a
holy mistake do you see what I'm doing
there either way it does seem to be
something of a new trend Queen Leticia
of Spain that's who we're looking at
there well she was pictured with a large
cutout at a place where it looks like
she's just left the iron on it doesn't
it uh opinions well I have to say they
are divided between fashion Brave and
ruined skirt again I think I might well
be at the bottom and I'm being told it's
112 quid apparently money well spent